[Music]
if you have a problem with the
patriarchy or with white people you'd
look at me and you'd go this guy
invented white people because he's so
white
he probably invented slavery he probably
was resistant to women voting so the
weird thing is I do feel like sometimes
even people talking about Trump or some
outlandish conservative opinion will
kind of present things to me they're
like well you know some people don't
support gay marriage like you maybe and
I'm like just because I look you know
like a prototypical white guy villain
who wants to kick immigrants out I'm not
I mean that's a form of bigotry in it
anyway I'm a great guy I grew up in a
small town in Indiana and I and I feel
as though living in New York or in LA or
even Chicago there is this
dismissiveness to people with differing
opinions where rather than explaining
our point of view we'd rather be right
John Kerry was running for president
versus Bush there was this I feel like
there was this collective thing like
well anyone who votes for Bush is an
idiot and I'm like that's not it that's
not how you convince people - that's not
how you persuade someone and and I feel
like being from a red state or from a
flyover area that sometimes people on
the East Coast or in LA there is this
dismissiveness of people that hold
different viewpoints rather than having
a discussion
there's just kind of like well they're
morons and the thing that worries me
about people that are you know a
supportive Virchow of Trump or angry
about Trump there's this absence of
dialogue instead of saying that someone
that supports Trump like what is it what
is it that you like there is this
self-satisfaction of like you're an
idiot and that's not how you convince
someone and I think that there's also a
this kind of denial that I think we
exist in when it comes to Trump or
people of radical opinions that we you
know emotionally disagree with is that
there are moments when they talk where
we go yeah well that's a decent point
but we never admit to that when Trump
talks when he gives speeches because
everyone watching this is watch Trump I
mean I stopped working to watch him
except because it's it's entertainment
is it's not as if he's not you know
articulate at communicating an idea it's
it's not that there aren't moments that
we don't identify with some of his ideas
overall again emotionally we might
disagree wholeheartedly but we might
identify with some of the fear we might
identify with the sheer raw kind of like
I don't want to lose
I want greatness we all identify that's
not that foreign he's not speaking a
different language but I think there's
also some geography that we forget that
I think that sometimes there is similar
to how we get our new
like there's people that watch fox
there's people that watch MSNBC I mean
I'm a news junkie and there was a time
when I brought up yeah
the Fox News and my friends were like
how dare you watch that and I'm like I
would go to the Soviet Union when it
still existed it doesn't mean I am a
Marxist you know it doesn't mean I
support communism I just think it's
weird that I maybe I personally I like
having friends that you know like
comedians that I perform with that open
for me on the road I had a guy who was a
libertarian and then the next guy who
opened for me was an Occupy Wall Street
guy and all three of us are friends I
kind of like people with different
opinions I like so and I'm not
dismissive of I mean I might casually
say you're crazy but I mean I love these
people and I also learn from them so
anyway my point is I'm a great guy
[Music]